of meticulous magpie oh i got a one of
one holy [ __ ] i'm fired up this is
number five
number five i got something good i got a
1015 drawing holy [ __ ]
no yes i did i'm keeping these okay i
know you are i know you are hey
everybody uh really excited to be making
this video and obviously we're going to
put it on audio to the podcast this is a
extremely ex extremely special
announcement in my world uh crosses some
of my greatest passions working with
some people i adore uh and uh and really
the expansion of the v friends universe
so we have this big brown box here if
you're watching visually if you're
listening just play along use your
imagination radio 1920 style um
we are
uh announcing many things here today i'm
gonna let my uh dear friend here to the
left uh kind of
take the baton and announce the macro
and then we'll get into the micro
execution within the macro uh so i'm
here with josh luber josh how are you i
am unbelievable
you took a red eye for this so i'm very
proud of you brother thank you trying to
will myself thank you for that answer
thank you fortunately there's so much
light in your office it's waking me up
it's great so um
why don't you why don't you give a
little context of uh what you got going
on and then we'll go into what we've got
going on well this is the launch of of
uh four things really um but uh at this
point a lot of people know that um i
have been working on trading cards for
quite some time um a lot of people know
that michael rubin and i started a
company and we were able to acquire the
licenses for baseball basketball and
football and that's amazing no that's
profound um but the thing that um i'm
actually most excited about and the
thing that i've been working on longer
since
uh the reason i left stockx was we've
always believed that there should be a
trading card brand for culture for
non-sports for all the important people
in the world other than athletes like
yourself like
every tv and movie and actor and rapper
and artist and fashion designer and um
we tried to create a set
at stockx back then it was kind of a
side project side projects don't work
for a lot of reasons
and that never never got out the door
and so we built a company we built a
brand and so
um we are launching uh xerocool
which is a trading card company for
non-sports so tops panini upper deck
you're cool or you're now you're for
trading card companies um but we get to
do the very first set um with b friends
which is pretty exciting so we're
launching the technology the brand the
site and the first physical trading card
set for an nft project
and there's probably no better
intersection of culture commerce
finance cards collectibles
than
where nfts are going and where v friends
is so it's a perfect mix to be able to
do that so that's
what's near i've only seen these uh i
have not seen these i've only seen these
in pictures this is the first time i'm
seeing them physically as well there is
a box right in front of me that we're
about to open i really wanted to capture
so what we're doing is for announcement
we are teaming up with zerocool this
profound new card company that we think
has huge upside as you can imagine from
the second i started drawing uh v
friends in the back of my mind i'm like
well there's going to be cards right you
know and so when how
and i'll never forget because i reached
out to you and we just started chomping
up and you're like you're not going to
believe this i'm doing this
and
this has been a year in the making um
and the way we decided to do it is look
v friends is a premium product so we
decided that we're gonna launch uh
befriends collectible cards in a very
small
high quality limited run uh and why
don't you explain the format of how
we're doing this yeah i mean this gets
to the entire thesis of uh of trading
cards of what we'll be doing at fnatic
collectibles of what we try to do at
stockx
but the whole idea is that these
products whether they're trading cards
nfts collectibles um these are not
consumer product goods these are not
products that should be priced at a
retail product
these are market driven products these
are supply and demand driven products
and so we did some of this back at
stockx where we release products as what
we call an ipo or initial product
offering but the mechanism is what's
called a blind dutch auction and we get
into the details but at the core it lets
the market it lets you set the price
not us and if the product is a is a
blast and everybody loves it and there's
not a lot of supply then prices go high
if it's inverse then it it goes low and
that's okay the product should be priced
as the market price prices it and so so
obviously we have links everywhere to go
to this um
this is dropping what march 8th is uh so
it sort of opens march 8th right and so
the the the whole idea excuse me no
worries
so what what what's really cool about
this mechanism and i was concerned
because we're not making a lot of this
like and we have such a big community
and discord such a big card community
there's just a lot of demand i'm like
how am i going to do this
and right and josh like well i'll tell
you how we do it we did this at stockx
we did this like i'll tell you exactly
how we're going to do it
everybody gets to
put correct me from wrong everybody gets
to put in a price yeah of what they
would like to pay
for the box
and whatever the low you know you have a
supply and whatever the lowest price is
that's what everybody pays
right so if if i'm the if let's say this
is not the case for the friends bucks
but if somebody does a 10 000 box drop
if the 10 000 person bid 197 dollars all
ten thousand people are gonna pay 197
that's how this is going to go down
you're as good as explaining this as
anyone works with this is oh i've been
i've been pitching them this idea for
five years now for five years now
excuse me um but when's the window close
it's so it's three days so opens on
march 8th for three days everybody has a
fair open chance to go to zerocool.com
so you've made a lot of mistakes and be
friends be friends one did you get uno
okay
but you agree that you've made a lot of
you would say you've made a lot of
mistakes
are you gonna make a meaningful like are
you gonna be smart this time yeah okay
but know the mechanism right so there's
actually a world where and we had this
on several um drops before where
somebody will build bid a million
dollars on the product knowing that in
the mechanism
they will actually get now if there's
you got to be careful right if there's
100 products and 101 people bit a
million dollars then like everyone's
kind of screwed yeah so
that so that doesn't actually work out
um but
but the idea is that um uh almost
everybody oh and usually it's over 95
percent of people end up paying less
than what their bid was well that makes
sense right 99 99 in theory everybody
but the lowest well usually what happens
is like you get you get clumps of prices
around like 100 150 200 and so you so
that's usually what happens right but
otherwise it's it's you know it's 99
yeah so
are we disclosing how many
yeah okay good yeah yeah yeah well so
and this is the this is the fundamental
uh like transparency
like transparency is is the the buzzword
so how many boxes of so so we made 1 000
boxes of e-friends each of which has one
pack with 10 cards in it so think like
national treasures flawless type of like
super premium quality can i just yeah
at this point we should open it
that's very funny
this uh i think a lot of you will get
this meme logan we love you brother um
all right
so
holy crap here's two of these two boxes
yeah so um
so these are are these two or i mean so
this is a case so you know it's real
this is this is real yeah yeah this is
online yeah so
we made a thousand boxes we're selling
800. so people want to hide seating
numbers because we're giving something
like you guys
giving it to some influencers my team
asked for some boxes for people i'm
putting a couple boxes in my closet so
all right
so this is it this is it it's not it's
not it's not it's the only thing it's
not shrink wrapped like it will be but
we brought this right from the factory
um
wow this is [ __ ] sweet no
joke yeah so for people in the card
world you'll recognize this because this
is
premium stuff
look i wish dustin had a camera you're
impressed right this is yeah the plan is
to go super ultra does everyone have one
sick sig
no no no no i i right because i only
signed 200 right right so all the um all
the math is on xerocool.com in terms of
i think there's 235 base cards there's
different parallels and you know you
obviously you know hand um signed and
and through some cards as well yeah so
so there's some really random right and
yeah there's fifth i was a 15 i drew 15
kind of uh drawings right on the card
well that was cool yeah all right so i
this is like the the definition of of
true chase like to get hand drawn
and by the way we don't know what's in
these like this isn't like pre-packed
for us so we might pull nothing we might
pull and we're gonna open it yeah yeah
yeah this is awesome i didn't even know
what we're gonna do yeah all right you
ready yeah yeah one at a time
you know this is unbelievable i've never
been a breaker so i don't know if the
the corrective rhino
this is unbelievable oh don't go fast
enamored emu all right here we go
sufficient shrimp
so this is a base card so i've never
i've had these these are so nice
um
oh boss bobcat
that's badass they're kind of a lost us
i mean like the oh i got something a
three of eight
juicy
jaguar
oh i have a i have a number to eight
shrewd
sheep
i like shoes so this is a rare yeah yeah
this is a rare so we tried to match it
with what i did on friends which is only
one of eight
exactly i got another rare secure
sparrow two of eight i got a number to
eight stoic slime i missed him in the
the stoic slime
oh i got a very rare one of five curious
crane
oh wow okay i see what's gonna work i'm
gonna i'm gonna pull from the back this
is how a breaker would do it right they
would pull they would pull the base card
from the back right
meticulous magpie
that is a base card of meticulous magpie
oh i got a one of one holy [ __ ] i'm
fired up
wild boar bubble gum
although i have two one holy [ __ ] i've
assigned one you got one
god damn it
i'm keeping these okay i know you are i
know you are
i'm getting this graded immediately uh
i've i've got a different story to tell
you about that okay this is number five
number five i got something i think they
[ __ ] planned this for they i got
something big
calm clam number to five i got a 1 to 15
drawing holy [ __ ]
no yes i did
i got
the smooth spider we really didn't plan
this
i know that look at this smooth spike
hold on i want that
that's so sick face base orangutang base
i give it i have a number to two
platypus which is pretty sick because
it's green
yes an epic that one's awesome and i
have so i have a one of one who was born
in 97. yes one of my favorites
that actually that's pretty cool [ __ ] i
pulled one of the best cards that's well
well now there's
14 left so this is so i have an
autographed level-headed lizard one of
one
love it so is your one-on-one
autographed
no just a regular bass but i got the big
hit this is one of the biggest hits what
does it say this future care is part of
vpn got it got it
oh man how is that [ __ ] possible
i'm a very lucky breaker
well i gotta tell you if it was your son
you would have voted yeah because
he's on him
um this is so much fun um so anyway for
everybody's listening uh
there's 800 boxes available 800 bucks
march 8th i like that i like what
numbers line up like that three days to
bid
uh
this is um obviously the beginning of
you know the journey with collectible
cards that i want to be on with me
friends it's very important to me
i'm going to put this in an incredibly
prominent spot
um on my shelf
sorry deadpool's first appearance i'm
going to be taking a secondary kind of
spot um
and so i am incredibly excited about
this
i'm incredibly excited about
xero cool give us a little more zero
cool love before we get out of here uh
bidding starts on march 8th zerocool.com
yep zerocoin.com three days um you know
you don't have to worry about bots or
your any of the nonsense everyone will
be able to have we studied markets and
talked to economists and talked to
professors for years to try to figure it
out this was like this was the most fair
way to sell high demand product and so
um so it just made sense for for all of
this um but you know
this is the start of the brand it's the
start of the
the business so um if you just think
about the world of possibilities whether
we do trading card sets for musicians or
actors or fashion designers so it's like
from polo g to the cast of euphoria to
you know to
you know uh
the kit you know you know ronnie like it
could really be anybody yeah yeah i mean
there's gonna be different sets and
different concepts yeah yeah kind of
like what i grew up with in the 80s
right like there was the michael jackson
cards there was the et cards there were
star wars cards there was so much team
yeah i got i have boxes of alpha cards
still sitting in my house i have i have
i have a bunch of super girl and he
he-man stuff somewhere in my office
anyway so but there's a ton of the
traditional ip i want to say that's the
easy part but that's the part that
people most know about we've never had
consistent sets for hey here's the 50
best uh artists here's the 50 best
fashion designers right whatever right
so like these and these people are as
important in culture as any athletes
ever
so
this is exciting for for me and
obviously this is part of fanatics
collectibles with
with tops and baseball and all the other
yeah
it's
for us jet fans
the epics
to the one of two's
um thank you thank you this is good luck
to everybody i know it's only 800 people
this is kind of gonna be the alpha
they'll hopefully be more things in the
future but this is um i wanted to do
something very very high-end very
on on message to what we're doing with
the friends and uh i hope this is an
opportunity for some of you that weren't
able to get series one to maybe get an
opportunity to make amends
thank you josh thank you xerocool.com
excited march 8th uh i may be dropping
this on march 7th or 8th or i don't know
we'll figure all that out but uh good
luck good luck good luck talk to you in
the discord about it thank you